لكننا أيضًا مع السيد Zelensky Mr.
الحفاظ على صداقتنا مع بوتين أيضًا
نحن في الموقف
الأمم المتحدة عندما يتعلق الأمر بالعقوبات
نحن نفعل كل ما هو مطلوب ضمن القواعد
لقد فعلنا ذلك حتى الآن و
الدول الأعضاء في الناتو
على الرغم من أننا لم نفعل روسيا
ووصلنا إلى أوكرانيا
و
السلاح الذي تلقيناه حتى الآن ، أو
هناك ظروف البنادق الحالية
في
ما الذي يظهره المستقبل للحديث عنه الآن
أعتقد أن الوقت سيكون مبكرًا ولكن ما هي الشروط؟
ما الذي يجلبه ، نحتاج إلى رؤيته
[موسيقى]
اندماج الوادي لا يأخذ قبضة
أصنعها
طوق بقناة فرق مثل الذهب 15 قطعة
قريبا نتيجة العم الحسين
هل هي أيضًا قنبلة يتبعها الأخرى من فضلك
علقت الحجر على العثمانيين كيز أو ربما
ليس منزل ماين كرافت في الوقت الحالي
سيدعم
هذا مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
هذه
ميزة Nova 4 منك يدويًا جيدة للأسف
بيلاروسيا
مع الحياة
[موسيقى]
ألينا
نهال
ها ها ها ها
اشترك